welcome to the livestream it's been a
while it's been busy I'll update
everybody on what's been going on and
what some upcoming with the show but
there is needless to say a lot on both
fronts and a lot going on this week as
well I'm actually flying out tomorrow to
a conference in Las Vegas a conference
that if you've been following the show
for any amount of time you know I and
Sam cedar and every once in a while a
couple other progressive media people
will broadcast from once or twice a year
usually I'm there twice a year and it's
Mike Papantonio --zz legal conference
and it really is a great meeting of the
progressive minds and a lot of ideas
discussed so much comes out of it every
time we go there so tomorrow I will be
traveling Ben Dixon will be guest
hosting as is often the case on the
Tuesday travel day to Vegas and then
Wednesday Thursday Friday I'll be
broadcasting from Las Vegas so I think
that that will be that will be a really
great thing and I'm looking forward to
it there is hopefully soon going to be
last Thursday Farren cousins from Ring
of Fire filled in for me on the
broadcast show and on the YouTube show
because I had a speaking engagement at
Worcester State University I spoke there
for about an hour on the topic of media
literacy and critical thinking and the
at my request I should say the entire
event was filmed including the my
lecture as well as the audience Q&A I
think was filmed and they've said
they're going to have it to me hopefully
sooner than later I don't know exactly
when and I will be putting that entire
lecture up on YouTube so that will be a
little bit of a preview for the possible
series of a dozen lectures that we are
considering doing for the YouTube
channel if and when we get to 2500
patreon subscribers so that is going to
be upcoming and this was a really good
lecture actually we talked about a lot
of just basic critical thinking and
epistemology and media literacy issues
that are sadly gone from most curricula
around the country at least in public
schools if they were ever there and just
basic skills that we should all really
have if we're going
analyze media messages so I think it was
a really good lecture standing room only
there was room for a hundred and eighty
people and something like 220 I mean
there were 30 40 or 50 people who were
standing along the back of the room so
good turnout at Worcester State
University one of the great state
universities here in the state of
Massachusetts and hope to have that up
on YouTube for you soon and I'll talk
about the upcoming lecture series in a
little bit on the program so a couple of
notes if this is your first live stream
with us it's been a little while since I
did when we're at nearly 400 thousand
YouTube subscribers now so it's
certainly possible that this is your
first live stream it is really live
unless it's not and you're watching a
replay right I mean sort of doesn't
really need more explanation you can use
super chat which is the dollar sign at
the bottom of the chat window to send
questions or comments which I will then
read and react to if there's questions I
will answer if it's comments I'll react
to them that is one great way to ask
questions during the stream super chat
number the second way is through stream
labs and we've set up stream labs comm
slash the david pakman show link is in
the video description and you can use
that works the same way a super chat
except it circumvents YouTube's 30% cut
that they take from Super chats and when
you do that you'll see your name pop up
you'll see the animation like we are
seeing because of Christina's dollar
contribution and also her name pops up
up here so very very exciting stuff and
I'll get to Christina's question in a
bit but both super chat & stream labs
comm / the David Pakman show
will trigger that so feel free to you
use both and Jacob all coming in with a
ten dollar super chat contribution and a
question and we will get to all those
questions I'll let them accumulate for
now new members and patrons who either
sign up for membership or become patrons
during the live stream both will get
live shoutouts and thank-yous for me and
I'm going to be talking a little bit
about what's upcoming with patreon and
the Dozen long-form lectures that were
working on putting together for you I
will also I might as well mention this
now I have 15 32 gigabite david pakman
show flash drives leftover from the last
time that we offered flash drives with
amber ship so I will offer the next 15
people who sign up for a yearly
membership it has to be a yearly
membership and you can do it with the
40% off code which is I voted 17 or
without it the next 15 people who sign
up for a David Pakman show membership at
david pakman.com slash membership i'll
send you a free 32 gigabyte david pakman
show flash drive I only have 15 of them
I was gonna announce this on the show
Wednesday but it might as well do it now
let the live Street livestream audience
get a head start on it you do have to
email me though and say hey I'd like one
of those flash drives here's my address
after you sign up on our website the
next 15 that all I have is 15 of these
32 gig memberships and lastly please
don't troll I saw people mentioning this
the band button is free the moderators
have been depth fully deputized to ban
people as necessary don't troll
obviously keep it too subtle trolling
that might go under the radar and even
subtle trolling the moderators are
getting quite good they might notice it
so please no trolling it's just it's
just not fun it's not funny and it's not
fun okay all right so I have so many
stories already for the next show I'll
be hosting which is going to be
Wednesday as I mentioned tomorrow
Benjamin Dixon will be guest hosting the
program from Atlanta Georgia I will be
traveling to a conference where I will
be broadcasting the rest of the week
Wednesday Thursday Friday there is this
really interesting article in The New
Yorker and I encourage you to read it
it's called the danger of President
Pence and a lot of the art the article
is pretty obvious stuff which is Mike
Pence is a dangerous religious right
ideologue and he's absolutely horrible
and completely anti progressive in every
conceivable way and if Donald Trump is
impeached
we would be dealing with the real danger
of Mike Pence that's not new okay but
the really interesting thing in The New
Yorker article if you sort of read
between the lines is that the anecdotes
about Mike Pence and his religiosity and
how that relates to Donald Trump expose
what you and I have probably known for a
long time but there's a lot of
right-wingers who seem not to realize
this they've been bamboozled by Trump
Trump is not only not religious and not
an
hi gay and not anti-abortion he seems to
actually find it kind of silly to be
anti-gay and anti-abortion and there's a
couple different instances that are
pointed out in this New Yorker article
there's one story that's told in this
article this profile about Mike Pence
where when people visit Donald Trump in
the Oval Office and Trump knows that
they've stopped by Mike Pence's office
Trump will sort of in an in a mocking
way say did Mike Pence make you pray
when you stop by his office if you are
actually the right wing Christian or at
least devout Christian who is
anti-abortion as Donald Trump claims to
be you don't mock another Christian and
ask if that Christian made you pray when
you visited his office that's number one
from The New Yorker article number two
Donald Trump was there's a meeting
described in this article where Trump
and pence were meeting with a legal
adviser and the topic of the repeal of
row v Wade came up and this is something
that's often talked about when there's a
discussion of Supreme Court nominees the
right has this idea of a litmus test on
roe v wade where they'd like to know for
the potential Supreme Court justice if
the possibility of repealing roe v wade
came up where would that potential
justice be and a legal adviser to trump
and pence astutely or not i mean it's
sort of obvious said you know if roe v
wade were to be repealed many states
would pass state-level laws proactively
legalizing at least some forms of
abortion and when when Trump and pence
were told that as the story goes Trump
turned to pence and said something along
the lines of see you've wasted all this
time and energy on it and it wouldn't
end abortion anyway if you're actually
an anti-abortion Christian the way
Donald Trump has characterized himself
his favorite book or a second favorite
book is the Bible and he's had this big
awakening on abortion you don't turn to
another fellow Christian fellow
anti-abortion elected official and say
see look at how much time you've been
wasting trying to ban abortion you just
don't do that and thirdly when the topic
of gay rights came up Donald Trump
apparently
pointed to pence and jokingly said don't
ask that guy he wants to hang them all
again not something you do if you are a
conservative Christian as Donald Trump
has portrayed himself to be now it's
obvious to anyone who has actually been
following the campaign for as long as
many of us have been following it it's
completely obvious Trump was never a
Christian Trump was never anti-abortion
and Trump was also never anti-gay but
it's more than that there are religious
rightists who have been tricked into
voting for Donald Trump under the guise
that he is religious and Donald Trump
might actually be hostile to the really
religious Trump's family has never been
religious Trump has never been religious
and I'm not pointing this out to say
Trump is some great progressive advocate
on social issues not at all Trump's
religion so to speak or his philosophy
so to speak is greed self enrichment and
self aggrandizement
if Trump thinks that by throwing women
who might need abortion services under
the bus he will do it if he thinks it
will further his political agenda
if Trump believes that taking an
anti-gay position when it comes to
employment discrimination or even gay
marriage or whatever he will do it so on
the one hand if you are actually a
religious rightist you have been tricked
and bamboozled by Donald Trump on the
other hand this is no endorsement of hey
we don't have to worry about Trump on
abortion and other social issues because
Trump will not hesitate to throw any
group under the bus and completely
disenfranchised them if he believes that
it will benefit him politically so this
is not good news for anybody right
there's there's no one that this is good
news from if you're a progressive you
should be worried because Trump doesn't
give a [ __ ] and he will throw you or
whoever under the bus as soon as he
thinks it will benefit in politically if
you're a Christian then you've just been
tricked into voting into a guy who that
is probably more hostile than you
believe to his point of view okay that's
one story that I'm going to be talking
about on on Wednesday from Las Vegas
there's also this other story that's
just been released that will burrows
Trump cabinet member Secretary of
Commerce is he Secretary of Commerce I
just had a sort of brain fart I believe
Wilbur Ross is Secretary of Commerce
Wilbur Ross accidentally left off a two
billion dollar disclosure from that form
Secretary of Commerce Wilbur Ross left
that off his financial disclosure that
he's supposed to fill out when he
becomes when he is vetted so it's never
oh I was overly cautious and listed even
things that I wasn't supposed to list
it's always oops I forgot to list some
absurd amount of wealth and or potential
conflict of interest that I have
financially but don't worry about that
because we're gonna amend that form it
happened with Jared Kushner dozens of
foreign contacts and I don't remember if
it was also financial with Kushner it's
happened endless times and it just so
happens that Wilbur Ross did the exact
same thing let's also talk about Rush
Limbaugh's recent comments and I hope I
I've already got a dozen stories queued
up for the Wednesday show and we usually
cover seven stories and I haven't even
we've not even gotten to what's gonna
happen on Twitter at 3:00 a.m. tonight
so it's going to be a tight show we're
also on Wednesday going to be
interviewing one of President Obama's
former speech writers which I think will
be really interesting rush limbaugh is
even becoming concerned with some of
Donald Trump's recent comments about
free speech and about censorship and
even Russia's a little worried that's
sort of like Hell freezing over when
Rush Limbaugh is going to express
concern serious concern what appears to
be non pandering serious concern not
concern trolling over a Republican
president you know that something is
weird or something is not going quite
right so we'll be talking about that on
Wednesday hopefully as well and we also
have heard this every time I talk about
circumcision it is a total [ __ ] show but
I for that reason I kind of like talking
about it there's a new study a
peer-reviewed medical study which the
details of which I will give you
on Wednesday if I get to it which shows
that it's an analysis of male
circumcision connected to women's health
and it shows that circumcision is better
for women's health and not just in
Africa that's a very common
anti-circumcision talking point which is
david any pro circumcision data with
regard to health outcomes is from Africa
and if you look at it in the West where
there are more modern sort of hygiene
practices as a result of culture and
technology you are going to not see
those benefits and this particular study
looked at women's health and it is not
just in Africa and I think it's gonna be
a people are gonna lose their [ __ ] over
it effectively so so get ready for that
ok let me tell you about what we have
going on with the patreon so once we get
to 2500 patrons as you see here we're at
1944 patrons we're trying to get to 2500
when we get to 2500 I may have mentioned
this some people joke I mentioned it a
lot but actually every time I mentioned
it people seem shocked by it I am
teaching as an adjunct professor at
Boston College one of the great not only
Boston area not only Massachusetts area
but one of the great higher education
institutions of the United States of
America Boston College I am teaching as
an adjunct professor there and the class
deals with a lot of issues related to
media literacy how do we identify
logical fallacies how do we identify
weak and strong arguments how do we
become informed consumers of news and I
mentioned the possibility of turning
those 75 minute lectures into a dozen or
so long-form lectures for YouTube with
my slides etc etc and the reaction was
almost unanimously positive of course
there were some people who called me a
dirty Jew cuck but it actually had
nothing to do with the lectures it's
just any time I asked the audience for
feedback somebody's going to call me
that so I'm not paying particular
attention to that but mostly people like
the idea of those lectures now it is
going to be a lot of work to put that
together so what we've set up is a
of 2,500 patrons and once we get there
we will go through the work we're not
afraid to do the work folks a lot of
people won't tell you that but we're not
we will put together these dozen or so
long form lectures and make them
available first to patrons but
eventually to everybody on YouTube so
this is a really good thing and it's
it's not based on money it's based on
number of patrons at patreon.com slash
david pakman show so if that's at all
interesting throw in a dollar throw in
$2 whatever the case may be and we will
make it happen we are at 1944 patrons
and just by the way if we do get I would
love to get to 1960 patrons today we're
only 16 patrons from that if we get to
1960 patrons during the livestream I
will create and release a 55 percent
membership discount code which you will
be able to use I will only tell you
about it here on the livestream and
currently we have a 40% coupon code
available on our website it's I voted 17
and I encourage people to take advantage
of that but if we get to 1960 patrons I
will create and release the 55 %
discount code and that's I think that's
a great thing okay let me get into some
of the super chat questions and the
stream labs contributions let me start
with stream labs these have been coming
in at stream labs comm slash the david
pakman show the first one is from
Christina who for $1 sent a contribution
asking what is your opinion of drug use
have you or have you ever experimented
have you or have you ever heard I guess
what you mean is am I or have I ever
experimented with drugs
I've not I'm not experimenting with
drugs right now and my experience
experimenting with drugs is pretty
limited but my opinion of drug use is
that I think that you know we we have
this completely arbitrary situation
where alcohol and cigarettes are
legalized and a whole bunch of other
drugs are illegal I don't really
understand the rationale for illegal
cannabis marijuana and legal cigarettes
I don't really understand that I don't
understand marijuana scheduling a
Schedule one meaning that it is just as
addictive and dangerous as heroin with
no medical value I mean we know that
there is medical value to particularly
the cannabinoids CBD in cannabis so I am
against I I believe drugs should be
decriminalized and dealt with as a
health issue and I think that there
should be legalization for numerous
drugs although I've not yet been
convinced that all drugs should be
legalized recreationally I'm not
decided against it but I I'm just not
not quite there yet a user going by the
name Pat Forde has sent a dollar stream
labs.com slash the david pakman show
contribution in Spanish and I would I'm
skeptical that this is that this is the
actual producer Pat Forde I will read it
in Spanish you know and I don't I don't
really actually this uses the Spanish
word for for [ __ ] and I'm not too into
that but I guess I'll read it as is and
then translated okay the comment is que
tal Marika s Pat estoy harto de souza
otra vez Barajas a las tres de la mañana
Orlando me elección de cafe this is this
is clearly translated by google
translate because it's an absolute
abortion Keurig no es tan mala yo puta
estaba hablando con Netanya tamale stove
para poner en tu propio lugar El Monaco
mio power Roger the truck the US so this
basically this is calling Pat a [ __ ]
and that that's not language I use the
user is saying that they're sick of my
drunk 3 a.m. diatribes
making fun of Pat's coffee selection
cure eggs aren't that bad you son of a
[ __ ] I was speaking with gnihton Pakman
presumably my little brother and we're
ready to put you in your place in the
well I'm lacking the brain fart here
Manny comeö is a nut house I guess is
what you would call it for destructive
drunks okay presented without comment
ten dollar stream lapse contribution
from a user going by Matt Palmer I
wonder if that's the Matt Palmer that I
know and is a friend of mine or not or
that doesn't seem like too common a name
so if it is Matt thanks man I'd
appreciate it
what Matt is doing you're a dad Matt you
need to be taking care of your kid not
not on my live stream although doing
both very very much resected Christina
has sent the dollar contribution my
goodness I do not usually say [ __ ] so
often I you do not usually okay Frank
macwrite has sent a $20 stream labs
contribution cos Kelley a chief of staff
Kelley responded to reporters quitting
rumors with one of his frustration is
you one of his frustration is you and
told reporters maybe develop some better
sources what has been reported
inaccurately so far previous Spicer more
all correctly predicted rump rumor or
not okay I'm having a little bit of
trouble parsing that but I think you're
the point you're making is one I've made
many times which is what major Trump
administration rumors have been proven
completely false
there are as yet unproven rumors but
there have really not been any Trump
administration rumors definitively
proven false
I guess that Rex Tillerson denied that
he was considering quitting but I don't
even know that it was a great denial so
I don't I don't know I that if your
point is we don't really have false
rumors all the leaks seem to be accurate
then yeah I completely agree with you
Christina with a dollar stream labs
contribution following up sorry for the
typo forgive me forgiving Christina of
course the nameless king has sent a $3
super chat contribution what do you
think of Millennials versus generations
II millenniums are deemed by the right
to be the lost generation and
generations II are supposed to be the
more conservative generation in the
saving grace for Western civilization I
thought that generation Z was very close
to Millennials according to Wikipedia
generation Z is the demographic cohort
after the Millennials know precise dates
for when that cohort starts or ends
demographers and researchers use the mid
90s to mid two thousands of starting
birth years and as of yet there is
little consensus regarding the ending
birth years yeah I don't agree with that
I you know there's a bunch it's very
popular to just slam Millennials as lazy
or entitled or whatever I I don't buy it
I don't buy it at all and in fact it's
Millennials that have been responsible
for some of the great startup companies
of our time now you could debate whether
some of those startups are genuinely
good for society or not but the idea
that Millennials are just lazy
Millennials are riddled with student
debt in a way that no prior generation
has been and are working in a time where
there are attempts being made to take
away their health care the only health
care system that they've known one where
you do have Obamacare subsidies they are
the first generation not first
generation but they are a generation
that has basically been in the workforce
during one of the biggest both real
estate and stock market run ups that
that Shiller what is his last name
Shiller irrational exuberance what is
his first name Robert Shiller
writes about in irrational exuberance as
probably a major bubble in both the
stock market and real estate housing
markets so yeah I think that it's very
popular to just slam millennion
Millennials but I think they're pretty
much bogus critiques okay let's go over
to super chat now we're caught up on
stream labs comm slash the david pakman
show contributions let's see what's
happening in super chat starting with
jacob ball who made a $10 contribution i
was surprised to hear that trump was
able to get along with the precedent of
the virgin islands i heard that the
president of the virgin islands is an
hour narcissistic small handed ass PS
I've missed your live streams yeah we
did the story today I don't know if you
saw this but Donald Trump recently said
during a speech to a hate group by the
way the American Family Association I
believe it was that he spoke to the
president of the Virgin Islands who of
course doesn't exist in the sense that
Trump is the president of the Virgin
Islands the US Virgin Islands and Puerto
Rico and Guam and and
missing a couple others ar-ar-ar they
don't have a president they are American
territories and yet Trump is a [ __ ]
isaiah Rowe has sent a five-dollar super
Chad hey David what's your all-time
favorite film
- Schindler's List that's like asking me
what my favorite book is right and if
you read with any frequency or watch
movies with any frequency how could you
have one favorite movie so I really
couldn't tell you I don't I don't have a
favorite movie I don't actually see
movies that often although I did see the
new Blade Runner on Friday Blade Runner
2049 the sequel to Blade Runner the
original blade Rumer Runner and I was
not particularly impressed
I really wasn't good it was good it
wasn't great Juan Garcia has sent a
$2.00 super Chad who were you rooting
for in the world cup I am rooting for
the Argentinian men's national team I I
know some people are disappointed
because the US Men's National Team has
flopped completely flopped and they
aren't even going to be making it to the
World Cup and I believe it was I don't
remember if it's Fox Fox Sports or NBC
News that paid some insane amount for
the rights to the World Cup broadcasts
in the US and the US isn't even going to
be in the World Cup but too bad for them
III the truth is I've always rooted I
was born in Argentina and I've always
rooted for the Argentinean men's
national team I've never been a fan of
the American men's national team there
are other sports where you know I I
follow American athletes but 100% I am
behind the Argentinian men's national
team we'll see how we do it was a little
dicey even during the qualifiers but
that is my number one team if what if
and when Argentina is not in it I also
like the team from Y our neighbors down
in Argentina and I also like the Mexican
team although there remember that coach
they had I believe his name was Meegan
everyda he was the guy who would just go
completely crazy on the sidelines he's
now a commentator when he was the coach
of the Mexican men's Nash
I'll team just watching him for
entertainment value was great but even
without him I still I would rank the
Mexican team as sort of my number three
the d2j bug has sent a to Canadian
dollar super chat c is for cookie that
is good enough for me couldn't have said
it better better myself thanks so much
for that contribution I appreciate it
Juan Garcia F marry kill Hillary Palin
and michelle bachman okay this is so i
would have to engage in romantic
relations we're trying to keep it clean
here with hillary Palin or bachmann I
would have to marry one of them and kill
one of them
I believe that I would kill this is this
is always completely completely
incorrect but I'm gonna I'm gonna
indulge it F marry kill Hillary Palin
and Bachmann um I think that I would I
wouldn't kill Hillary I'd kill Palin or
Bachmann F Mary I think that I would oh
boy that is that is really tough I would
kill
I would kill Bachmann I think I would
kill Bachmann because I find her the
most repulsive
I would probably if I had to be
romantically involved probably Palin and
then I would marry Hillary Clinton I
guess by process of elimination I mean
it's all it's it's all a little bit
scary and touching yeah first F marry
kill on a live stream so that we got
that out of the way and I think we can
all I guess appreciate that I don't know
okay let me do some new member thank
yous I mentioned at the beginning of the
live stream I have 15 32 gigabite David
Pakman show
flash drives available and I said that
the next 15 people who sign up for a
yearly membership it has to be a yearly
membership get one for free
Shawn Quintero has signed up for
membership at david pakman.com slash
membership he has used the 40% discount
code I voted 17 and he has claimed one
of those fifteen one of those fifteen
32-gigabyte
Pakman show flash drive so Sean thank
you thank you for supporting the show we
will get that flash drive out to you I'm
not back in the studio until next Monday
tomorrow I'm traveling to a conference
and broadcasting live remotely for the
rest of the week so we will send that
out to you on Monday but one of 15 flash
drives has been claimed can you imagine
40% off of a yearly membership and a
free david pakman show flash drive for
all of your friends I mean that is
really really amazing so I encourage you
to sign up a couple of other people also
signing up with no flash drive because
they did monthly memberships Chad mink
as well as Kimberly vici vote both of
whom have signed up at david pakman.com
slash membership on the patreon side
nobody know new patrons so far were at
1944 we want to get to 1960 today just
throw a dollar in really if you can
afford if 12 dollars in a year is an
amount that would not impact you
financially I am suggesting that you
throw in a dollar a month at patreon.com
slash david pakman show because it's
really not a lot of money but it can it
can add up quickly as you can see and if
we get to 2500 patrons we are going to
be producing and releasing a series of a
dozen or so long-form lectures taken
from the lectures I've been giving in my
Boston College class that I'm teaching
as an adjunct they will first be
available to made available to our
patrons and then eventually we will make
them available to everybody on YouTube
so please check that out
patreon.com slash david pakman show I
promise you this folks this I can tell
you a lot of people don't know this but
it's true if you make a patreon
contribution I will thank you and sing
your praises live during the stream and
I think that that maybe that's exciting
maybe it's not exciting to people but
it'll happen nonetheless okay let's go
over to stream labs comm slash the david
pakman show a lot more contributions and
questions coming in a user going by the
name join the discord there is a discord
server where our viewers debate each
other and
from other shows and it's fantastic
what's going on has sent a contribution
saying David I just want to let you know
that I support your bachelor lifestyle
yeah so the reference here is that I had
an audience question a few weeks ago
saying hey David can you list some of
the reasons that people either have
canceled memberships or refused to get
one and there was a guy who emailed me a
few weeks ago and said David I like your
show I like what you're doing I think
it's valuable but I refuse to make a
financial contribution or sign up for
membership because I am married with
three kids and I'm your age and you're
not married and don't have kids and thus
I don't want to support your bachelor
lifestyle which didn't really make sense
to me I decide what to support
financially based on the merits of the
programming or the endeavor I don't look
at the personal life of the individual
and say well I'm gonna evaluate their
personal life and decide whether or not
to support them and what's funny is a
whole bunch of people signed up for
membership and wrote and saying hey you
know what I'm a single parent and I
really didn't like that guy's email so
interestingly enough that brought in
more supporters than that one guy but
yes I appreciate it thank you for
supporting my bachelor lifestyle Eric
Patterson has sent a five-dollar
contribution at patreon labs.com slash
the david pakman show greetings haven't
heard today's show as yet so if we give
me if you've addressed this how was your
presentation in Worcester last week very
good I addressed this at the beginning
of the stream I did a speech a lecturer
at Worcester State University last week
it was standing room only and it went
really well and it was filmed and I am
told that they will have the video for
me I don't know when but soon I believe
and I will put the video on the YouTube
channel so that people can check it out
vegans for Pat has sent a $2.00 stream
labs.com slash the david pakman show
contribution where's Pat bin
he's been mostly on the show so he
hasn't been anywhere he's been in studio
gigantic meaty balls have sent a dollar
stream Labs contribution om8 I caught an
in kangaroo today you wouldn't reckon
put it on the barbie and oh boy a koala
just killed the okay killed the EMU
trying to eat my crops still sad about
our defeat in the EMU Wars alright love
you Dave I'm Aussie Aussie I don't know
how they pronounce it by the way alright
well thank you very much
not'n I can't really think of what to
comment there Christina has sent a
dollar stream Labs contribution you look
the very handsome wearing your tuxedo on
your Instagram I was wondering what is
your opinion of marriage are married
relationships better then or more
committed unmarried is it unrealistic to
be monogamous for life okay so a couple
different things here yeah I was wearing
a tuxedo at a friend's wedding my
opinion of marriage is that it is an
institution that I believe is a
tradition that is in society but I don't
find it particularly necessary I don't
think that you are necessarily more
committed to your partner if you are
married you certainly are involving
potentially lawyers accountants and
governments in ending the relationship
if you decide that you want to and for
some people they believe that those that
friction to separating makes it a more
committed relationship but I don't
believe that I want to believe that is
it unrealistic to be monogamous for life
I don't know I've read pretty
interesting papers arguing that
particularly with extended lifespans the
idea of monogamy for life is less
realistic but I don't I don't really
have strong feelings about it I'm you
know socially I'm very libertarian and
I'm sort of like hey people want to be
monogamous or not whatever works for
them if they can make it work by all
means have at it if people want to get
married or not I I just don't really
think that much about what other people
are doing within their relationship as
long as they're not trying to dictate
other people's relationships Brian has
sent a dollar stream labs contribution
who do you think is a stronger player
Leo Messi or said here a Guido both
players on the Argent's
in men's national team I think Messi is
the stronger player I mean a Guido is a
is an excellent soccer player but he is
not at the level of Leo Messi who is
arguably the greatest soccer player
right now and one of the greatest of all
time a widow is very very good on the
Argentinian men's national team but I
believe that it's not really a contest I
think that Messi is definitely the
better player $99 stream lapse
contribution from Eric Patterson who
says challenge to others on the stream
beat my donation you would need to
contribute 99 dollars and one cent in
order to beat Eric Patterson's
contribution thank you Eric very very
exciting stuff and on that note let me
do a few other thank-yous we started the
evening with 1944 patreon contributors
should beep please Abebe please come
back has made a $2 a month pledge on
patreon
Elliot Avila has made a dollar a month
pledge on patreon Billy Cromer has
pledged $1 a month on patreon and we
also have there must be some fourth
pledge in there because I'm seeing
written 1944 right now
maybe not haven't gotten the
notification yet so anyway thanks to the
three or four new patrons were at 1944
tonight's target is 1960 what is 1960
mean if we get to 1960 patrons that's
only 12 more that is only something like
3% of the people currently watching the
stream if we get to 1960 patrons tonight
I will create and release to you a 55
percent discount code and for membership
and announce it on the stream and on
that note we do have another new member
that new member is Jason Ramsey Jason
has taken advantage of the 40% discount
code which is I vote at 17 Jason is now
a david pack
remember he gets instant access to the
commercial-free
broadcast show to the world famous bonus
show and if he wants it he can get one
of the 14 remaining 32 gigabite david
pakman show flash drives I have 15 of
these flash drives available I said that
the first 15 people to sign up for a
yearly membership with or without the
discount I will personally send out to
you a 32 gigabyte david pakman show logo
flash drive one of those is spoken for I
don't know yet if Jason wants one of
those flash drives or not but in either
case there are 13 or 14 of those left
and I am encouraging you I am
encouraging you to take advantage of
that because why not
why not Jakob ball has now succeeded
Eric Patterson as the top donor for
today Eric Patterson made a $99
contribution to the stream labs.com
slash the david pakman show platform
saying who can beat my donation and now
Jacob Ball has made a $99 and one cent
contribution via super chat with the
message just got a promotion two weeks
ago
suck it Eric Patterson and Jacob now has
become the top contributor today during
the live stream and that now moves the
bar to ninety nine dollars and two cents
ninety nine dollars and two cents would
be the next high-water mark for
contributions during today's live stream
and del Dinkins has added a $2
contribution through super chat which is
the dollar sign at the bottom of the
chat window ok let me tell you a little
bit about upcoming interviews and
upcoming long-form pieces on the show I
have been teasing a long-form piece
about race and IQ for a very long time
race and IQ is very interesting to me
race and IQ is a subject that both the
left and the right have problems with
the left often doesn't want to talk
about differences in IQ
categorised by what we know of as race
the they just don't want to talk about
it there are sometimes conversations
that the left struggles with having
because they believe merely talking
about it opens up conversations that
they don't want to have and I understand
that the right has problems with race
and IQ because they often believe that
if you can find differences in average
IQ based on race that justifies
particular policies which may be
discriminatory or that it indicates that
just because we have identified a
correlation in race and IQ that there is
a causal relationship there so both the
left and right have some pretty serious
problems on the issue of race and IQ I
think the problems on the right are way
bigger than the problems on the left
with race and IQ we are about 90% done
with the background research for a
long-form piece on race and IQ that I
believe is going to be really really
good and we have one of our viewers who
is really good with this particular
topic he is reviewing it we're really
getting input from a lot of different
people we're going to address the Sam
Harris podcast bell curve controversy
it's gonna be really really good okay so
that's upcoming on the David Pakman show
we also have some really really good
interviews upcoming on the Wednesday
program I'm going to be speaking with
David litt David litt at age I believe
24 became a speechwriter for President
Obama his experience is fascinating and
we're gonna interview him on Wednesday
next week by popular demand I will be
interviewing Josh Zepps Josh Zepps has a
podcast and he has a number of other
credentials and I am going to be he's an
Australian media personality and I'm
gonna be speaking with him he is a
satirist he is a TV show host and he has
a lot of interesting stuff in his
background so I'll be speaking to him
next week by popular demand I will be
interviewing Abigail Marsh she is an
expert on child sociopathy and I am
interested in the topic of sociopathy
and I've been reading a lot about
if you are there interventions that can
be done if sociopathic traits and
psychopathic traits are identified in
young children early and we're gonna be
talking to Abigail Marsh about that next
week on the program I will also be
interviewing Scott page Scott page has a
book called the diversity bonus he
argues that diversity and this kind of
relates to the James the more Google
diversity memo controversy Scott page
believes that there is a measurable
financial benefit to different types of
diversity at businesses so his argument
is put aside the issue of political
correctness diversity is good business
and we're gonna critically analyze that
you can you can believe that for sure
and then we will also be speaking to who
else do we have lined up let me see here
we'll be speaking to Neil Howe and Neil
Howe is one of the I guess we would call
him patriarchs of Straus how
generational theory and that's
interesting because it's something that
Stephen Bannen former Trump chief
propagandist has read a lot into and
we've got him on the program and I think
it's absolutely fascinating so fantastic
week fantastic week of programs coming
up next week as well as one more this
week okay Eric Patterson Wow I need to
take a sip of water out of my University
of Massachusetts mug Eric Patterson has
now once again bested the previous high
with $100 stream labs.com slash the
david pakman show contribution that is
now the high-water mark and he adds
let's have a contribution war support
the David Pakman show
I don't think anybody can beat me
tonight 204 dollars so far who wants to
take me on
so now 100 dollars and a penny is the
the I guess of the amount needed to
surpass Eric with the largest single
contribution
Jamal Swift $10 through super chat do
national or local network news programs
ever come calling if so so who and is it
an interest of yours you know they
really don't and I don't do if I was
really going to try to seriously get
myself booked on national media more
often what I should be doing is every
single day sending out a little media
pitch to all of my contacts in corporate
media and saying hey here's my take on
this issue I'm available for interviews
I don't do it and partially I don't do
it because it's a lot of time commitment
you have to go to the studio where they
have the satellite uplink they want you
there a half hour early and and it
hasn't really moved the needle very much
for me before I think that if I were
able to get on a program like Bill
Maher's real time or even Joe Rogan's
podcast I believe that that would move
the needle in terms of bringing new
people into my audience way more way
more than would then have my appearances
on CNN or Fox News or other channels
like those so no they don't come calling
and I don't go looking for them and it's
not really an interest of mine to and
actually more like three years ago if
you had asked me what's the end goal
with the David Pakman show it would be
that it gets so big that it gets bought
out or picked up or that I get hired by
some corporate media outlet but the
truth is my schedule is too good and the
total editorial control I have is too
good for me to want to do that and have
a whole bunch of people analyzing
everything that I'm saying receiving
notes all the time I just want to get
notes from the audience with opinions
about what I'm doing the last thing I
want is that that corporate structure so
no I'm not it's not particularly an
interest of mine although at one point
it absolutely would have been let me say
thanks to Huang Garcia who has made a
$2.00 a month pledge at patreon.com
slash david pakman show thank you very
very much quant appreciate that we
started the evening at 1944 patrons
we've since had a few new patrons
trickle in and we are now up to one
thousand nine hundred and forty-eight
the target for this evening was 1960
patrons I don't know that we're gonna
make it there I don't know that we're
gonna make it there and what I said was
that if and when we got to 1960 patrons
I would create and release for you a 55
percent membership discount code and you
could take advantage of that and sign up
but I don't know that we're gonna make
it if it's just a dollar it gets us one
closer you don't have to contribute a
lot of money those dollar contributions
really add up
the two dollar contributions really add
up as well but let's do it we've still
got some time 1960 we just need 12 more
of those contributions let's make it
happen okay let me jump back into the
super chat we have a super chat from
Olivia van gada who says for five
dollars why are you following corporate
media by refusing to report this scandal
of Lies from Las Vegas massacres
ever-changing narratives don't you care
I don't know what you're talking about I
don't know what you're talking about
I've been following the Las Vegas
shooting story closely and I don't know
what it is that you're talking about and
I don't know if this is a conspiratorial
sort of comment or if there's a
particular thing but if someone can tell
me exactly what which aspect of the
quote narrative is a scandal of lies I
would be happy to look at that I just
don't know that I just don't know what
you're talking about but I can assure
you I am NOT in cahoots with anybody in
ignoring any particular narrative Eric
Patterson Eric Patterson has sent a $5
stream lapse contribution saying Pat has
been with the show now for one year
what's your opinion of his growth
contribution and maturation over this
past year name something you've learned
from him that was useful well Pat is
chock full of interesting nuggets of
information so I couldn't name just one
thing because there are dozens of
factoids that I've learned from Pat that
I've integrated into my knowledge but
there's no doubt that Pat's
contributions to the program have been
significant his behind-the-scenes work
which people that will never see
has advanced by leaps and bounds and
people love hearing from pat on the
program as well and on the bonus show
and yeah I mean I can't tell you the
maturation of Pat who came in wide-eyed
and bushy tailed and naive to the world
of hatreds he has now been fully exposed
and corrupted by them and it has been
incredible to see and I think he's
dealing with it as well as anybody could
the daily criticisms from hatreds and
witnessing the anti-semitism that I am
constantly riddled with every day and
all sorts of crazy stuff on the
voicemail and all of this so yeah Pat's
been exposed to a lot and really thrown
to the Wolves in a lot of ways and he's
doing quite well he's doing quite well
so that is a very very exciting thing
okay I am going to have to cut today's
livestream a little bit short I've got
to pack and get a whole bunch of stuff
ready because I am gonna be broadcasting
live from this conference the rest of
the week I'm going to try to line up a
live stream with Sam cedar of the
majority report I don't know yet who
else from the progressive media world
will be at the conference in Las Vegas
but I hope to bring you some live
streams with them and that I think would
be it would be different for sure and on
that note before we wrap up Kristina has
sent in $1 stream lapse contribution you
said if you came into money you would
invest it into real estate but mentioned
you rent what is your reasoning with
rent versus buy no I don't rent I
personally own I might I might rent out
real estate but I own and do not rent so
if I was unclear on that one Christina I
do apologize I do apologize I would
never want to lead you astray when it
comes to real estate transactions that I
am or am not involved in and on that
note thanks to everybody for joining me
more live streams hopefully from Las
Vegas later in the week